you know if any of you remember this
show called flavor of love
flavor of love like it was like a guy
[ __ ] with 30 hot chicks just banging
all of them and then throwing them all
out one by one so there's only one left
i mean it's a good situation and like
it became this phenomenon brett michaels
did it they had like this format kept
getting repeated and believe it or not
that the producers the network reached
out to me and asked me to do the same
[ __ ] format
like stevo of love flavor of stevo
and i just couldn't do it i said man
there's no way i thought to myself
there's no way i'm gonna let 30 chicks
tell the entire world how fast i come
and that's the only reason i didn't do
it the only reason i didn't do it dude
and i was legitimately thinking that
dude is that really the reason
i mean dude i was just like dude i'm
gonna hook up with these chicks there's
gonna be cameras all over the [ __ ]
house they're going to have their little
room that they're hanging and they're
all going to be going
ain't going to lie steve but hey
excitement makes that happen
excitement makes it happen and i'm going
to lie if you ain't too excited then
it's going to take you longer right
exactly but if you're really excited oh
you're coming fast right believe me
trust me i already know i got eight kids
yeah but dude the potential the
potential for that show like with all
the wild like if it's like these dirty
women they're they got challenges
they're vying for stevo's love are they
willing to how much wasabi will they
snort to [ __ ] pass to to get the date
like i'd be jesus it could have been so
[ __ ] intense
i mean i don't know i didn't i didn't do
it because i know one thing i know one
thing the girls that you pick
in order for it to work with you and
that girl
they had to be just as crazy as you man
if they're not as crazy as you it's not
it's not a match
and it wouldn't work i i'm i'm very much
in love i'm engaged to be married
congratulations thank you and and my
girl
it's not that she's crazy as i am she
can just handle [ __ ] you know she gets
it you know she she can uh i wouldn't
say my girl's crazy but she can handle
crazy she's not she's not [ __ ] uh
scared of crazy and and it's pretty it's
pretty intense but dude
like
if if you don't want to be the
grandfather the father of gangster rap
that you are damn well the father of
[ __ ]
dating shows like that thank you man
thank you man yeah man i um i did my
thing i didn't how did that come
together dude like did someone just they
just
they reached out to you like well well
it all started it all started from
when i uh
first started in reality tv and i did a
show called surreal life
oh damn that came real quick three right
so real life three and on that show
it was myself
my boy
jordan knight lead singer from new kids
on the block huh bridget nelson bridget
nelson right
charo from the love boat okay
and also a young lady named ryan starr
who was on american idol but she i got
booted off okay and everything and also
um
my boy dave coulier i came from full
house yeah
that's my boy man i missed dave so
anyway so um
once in real life me and bridget ended
up falling in love oh damn that's right
right on surreal life we ended up
falling in love and then
and then they gave me and bridget our
own tv show called strange love
yeah remember now strange love
strange first of all
okay that's a real life show that that i
fell in love with brigitte on right that
show was number one
then they gave me and bridget our own
show strange love
strange love one
was number one then we did strange love
two
it was number one
then we did strange love three
which was number one
then when bridget went back to italy to
be with her family
then
my producers asked me they said well
flav you're printing money flav what are
you gonna do for love now i said
i don't know they said well do you watch
the bachelor i said i heard of it but
i've never really watched it they said
great we're going to put you in the
house with with with 30 girls flav how
many girls was it i don't know if i
would say 30 like as a so uh
my first
season they put me in there with 25
girls wasn't 30 it was it was 25.
and i had to narrow it down to one right
right they said we're gonna put you in
the house with 25 girls flame and you
just gotta just narrow it down to one so
i'm like okay let me see how this works
so we shot flavor of love one that
season right there
i picked this young lady named hoops
you know what i'm saying from detroit
michigan you know what i'm saying
and and not only that but hoops
ended up with shaq for a while
you know what i'm saying in the hall 9 i
know that they're still cool i don't
think they're together now but i know
that her and shaq is still cool you know
what i'm saying but but nikki man she
was she was great you know what i'm
saying after flavor of
of love won
which was number one yeah dude right
number three there's got to be a level
up then we shot flavor of love too
and flavor of love too
was my biggest season because they put
me in the house with 25 more girls and i
narrowed it all the way down to one and
i picked
delicious
right
and that was my biggest season i ended
up bringing vh1 its most viewers ever in
its history
7.5 million viewers
and vh1 has never ever seen those
numbers ever again as we sit here and
speak so i still hold a record right now
at vh1 damn
but that show was number one
then we did flavor of love three
the flavor of love three
was the number one show
so when i left vh1 i left vh1
at number one
okay so let me ask you this you had to
have had like new contracts for each
show right like surreal life he probably
had some boilerplate kind of dancing
with the stars looking contract because
everybody's like a group of celebrities
in there and then you come out of that
and say okay now we're going to give you
your your own show with bridget and so
that's probably going to look a little
different of the contract because now
it's really just your show so you're
gonna get taken care of i mean well each
show you're gonna have different
contracts right contracts right and all
i'm saying i mean i guess they they
could throw out the bigger your audience
gets the more
you you have
you you have a chance to renegotiate
right i mean and in some cases
absolutely and particularly when there's
when there's crazy success you can
renegotiate we look at the jersey shore
kids there was how many of those [ __ ]
kids like like six eight and they were
each getting like a hundred grand per
episode right but now you're the you're
the one there's only one of you
like the 25 chicks they're they're not
really they're like they've got no
leverage they're lucky to be there
they're not getting paid [ __ ] you're
getting all that money and that's after
you just did the contract for strange
loving and then you're number one there
so okay now they know you're the golden
goose so then and it's beautiful that
you're switching shows because on each
series they're going to have options
where they're going to be able to renew
you you know you're kind of locked into
that contract but you're changing shows
you go from surreal life to strange love
and now you're doing flavor below you've
proven your track record by the time you
get to flavor of love to where now
you're holding all the cards so your
contract for flavor of love you gotta
have like back end [ __ ] well let me
see you produce your credit you're gonna
well let me say this man and which is
real sad to say but
i didn't really have the right team
behind me
going into television you know what i'm
saying and
and and and i my contracts wasn't really
negotiated in my favor
it was it was negotiated more into vh1
and 51 minds failed today i had a
meeting with 51 minds yeah like like
years later down the road
and uh they told me guys shouldn't say
this but here i'm just gonna i'm not
gonna say who said this but they said
that when when they they after flavor
love then they started to rock a love
with brett michaels right with brett
michaels and they also did did one with
ray j as well yeah with ray j and then
it was like daisy and love it was a
[ __ ] phenomenon right they even did
one with new york yep i love new york
they did they did it over and over man
they they milked that [ __ ] wow okay so
i'm not saying who it was somebody
told me that when like i think it was
the first season with brett michaels
right that before they even just when
they got there before they even started
[ __ ] filming they had they had not
started filming yet but they all got to
the location they said on the first
night [ __ ] had like a foursome
he's straight boned
four chicks at the same time right
michaels
before they even started filming wow
wow yeah now maybe that's a rumor i
can't [ __ ]
say the source i can't confirm
he's my good friend yeah he yo man he's
real he's real people man sure he is
and
and his favorite his famous line on that
show which was my favorite is he would
tell the girl
hey
would you stick around and let me rock
your world
i'm like go ahead brett that's my dune
right there
good dude man yeah i love me some bread
and bread loves yourselves with flavor
flav by going live
yeah you're an american treasure bro
thank you man yeah you're an american
treasure and it breaks my heart to think
that you had so much leverage
that like that these [ __ ] jersey
shore kids could have ended up doing
better out of their tv show
like you know hey look look look look uh
snooki
yeah snoopy yo she blew she blew the
[ __ ] up and not only did snooki blow the
[ __ ] up or so did paulie d yeah come on
man he ended up djing all over the world
yeah come on man
he's the man yeah that's right he's the
man dude that's right um
but even if you didn't get the best
business
uh out of vh1 for all the number one
shows that you listed off right it's not
like you're doing bad because dude i'm
telling you that we got our wild ride
sign
and i had i just picked the color i like
that i like that sign green i picked the
color color money i picked the color
green because that's because we were
like okay well we're going to
flavorflame's house right now we're
driving the studio van and i'm like i
didn't know the address i'm trying to
take care of emails and [ __ ] in the back
of the rv while we're driving right and
then i kind of look up and and scott and
scott says we dude
we're in bel air like we're like it's
like it's like [ __ ] fresh prince of
bel-air like this and like damn this is
like mansion city i saw i looked around
we pulled into your estate and i said
yes sir i said [ __ ] flavor flavor is
is balling and this sign is gonna be
green today
no doubt no doubt man hey i love the
sign though well thank you man i love
the sign and i love going on wild rides
dude i love your studio man it's a it's
a killer land i was comfortable in there
i appreciate it man just kept going in
the car man dude everybody just check
out stevo flavor flav the flavor flavor
flav
show did an original podcast man ah
so dude where
this how long have you lived here in bel
air plus this is just your second house
because you actually like right right i
actually live in vegas too as well you
know what i'm saying but uh here man
it's been like i don't know maybe
nine years now okay you know that i've
been here as well and so she got this
place nine years ago and if if uh
i mean the
flavor of love show had pretty well run
its course at that point
like uh
i mean that that's a move when you're
like okay i'm gonna buy a mansion and
not beverly hills [ __ ] bell
yeah i'm gonna buy
a mansion in bel air
like
so what motivates that move is it like
dude i'm sitting on some some loot from
vh1 like
like uh that was the chicken business
going on fire at that time yeah like
right like uh public enemy like just
still
bringing in money
right
like what's the biggest revenue stream
like at the paid for this bel air
mansion is it public enemy
tv
chicken i say i say all of it combined
you know i'm saying all of it combined
man you know what i'm saying one
uh public enemy
had its own reverend we we had our own
revenue stream
you know i had my own revenue stream
with public enemy which was different
from my chicken franchise
revenue stream
you know what i'm saying
and that was a lot different from my
reality tv revenue stream you know what
i'm saying
each other so in order for me to make
this work where i am i had to just put
it all together yeah and combine it
together and i just had to just you know
spend my money wisely
yeah that's good and and to make it work
for me
it's called stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and if you go on amazon and
type in stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and order yourself a bottle
you'd be really helping me because right
now we're ranked number 30 on all of
amazon and if you buy a bottle we might
go up the ladder and that would mean a
lot so please get on amazon and buy
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude